[Music]
Hassan it is so good to be here with you
today you as well yeah thank you for
having me of course so let's start at
the very beginning tell me about your
founding story yeah yeah so you know if
we rewind back to like 2019 I was at
Google at the time but I was running a
product Studio that started you know
years ago and so we would be helping
traditionally non- Tech Founders build
their Tech startups and so at the time
you know video has become pretty popular
we're all addicted to TiK ToK by then
right so personalized video was sort of
this emerging topic and we actually told
them like hey how about you send out
personalized videos manually and let's
see how it works it actually worked
amazingly like response rates were you
know far higher than traditional
channels and we're like okay this
actually works but they soon came back
and said hey this was like really
painful like you know 200 videos took 12
13 hours to record edit send this is not
scalable so sort of a light bu moment
why not use Jour of aitech to make
personalized video skillable so very
cool so then walk me through if I'm a
company to today trying to use your
technology how how does it work yeah so
it's super super simple so it's really
you can at home you can be on your
computer you give us 2 minutes of data
where you know you basically read off a
script that we give you and then we're
able to create a really really high
quality AI clone of you and so that's
pretty much it we'll clone your voice in
your face so that you can then send
thousands of personalized videos at the
same time it would take you to record
and send just like a couple wow who are
your customers and who's your target
market yeah so so we focus on sales and
marketing teams today so our customers
include like Salesforce ramp and then a
couple really awesome on as well the
chain smokers are also one of our
customers so super super awesome group
and yeah we typically Target sales and
marketing teams that are looking to
scale out their Outreach so it might be
you know a sales marketing team that's
using like their CEO to send out
thousands of like thank you videos or
may A salesperson reaching out and so
that Personal Touch it goes a pretty
long way how do you look at you know the
new legislation that may be brought into
place or ethics as they're thinking
about how to scale your company we
welcome sort of Regulation we've always
built a platform around you know giving
power to the user and giving power to
the individual which means that like you
can't upload someone else's video and
clone them it won't let you we run face
ID and voice ID checks to ensure that
you are the person that you're trying to
clone so for us you know we would rather
work with legislators to to build like
very safe regulation that doesn't hinder
actual you know progress in the space
but ows it to be used in safe
ways now talk to me about how your sales
growth has has gone from from inception
to to right now what have you been
seeing yeah so you know we officially
launched we were sort of stealth and
beta for you know all of 2022 so then we
finally launched towards the end of
January of 23 and the growth been
incredible we grow in 203% month over
month we exceeded you know a mill of
Revenue probably you know towards the
the middle half of this year and our TR
on track to end you know right around 2
mil of of Revenue so super super excited
about that and next year we're we're
excited to you know multiply that many
times over hopefully is there one
business rule that you always operate by
no matter what only deal with nice
people you know it's not worth dealing
with with people who aren't nice and
also I think it goes back to the ethics
piece which is like always take a step
back and evaluate what you're doing and
make sure that you're doing it for good
and not just for like you know greed
that's good to life to absolutely you
can use it for
both so looking back is there anything
that You' wish you'd known the day
before starting your company that you
tell yourself you know back then and
that you wish you'd know now hm to just
like take a little bit more time for
yourself right because you know I think
that like as Founders you're like always
going a million miles per hour and I
think that now looking back we didn't
really celebrate the small wins enough
because we're like oh yeah there's
there's something else to to do right
and so you know if I were to tell you
know a younger version of may i' be like
hey take the time to like actually
celebrate the small wins you know that
first sale that first you know
investment that first yes whenever
you're going through fundraising right
celebrate those small wins instead of
just being like yeah well we have this
other thing to do now right
right what would you like your legacy to
be if you ask like overall I think what
I'd like my legacy to be is just like
leaving the world a little bit better
than I I found it and also just like you
know putting more smiles on people's
faces right like I like I think that
like that's what I really love about tab
this is like when people get that first
video whenever like a fan gets Outreach
from someone they really care about and
they're happy right delivering moments
of Joy so if I can do that over the
course of my entire life I think I think
it's pretty
[Music]
good